please welcome kat graham
so exciting what an honor to be a drew
gooder i'm gonna use that
from now on that's in addition to my
title drew getter officially
so well you also have like a peta award
and you were nominated for an emmy for a
short
film a psa you did for black lives
matter yes i am a total drew getter
i i like to do that my free time i'm so
honored you're even putting my
name and all those incredible
well-deserved accolades
kat we're pretty amazing i mean the
stuff that you've done with the
world food program is pretty remarkable
and you just have always been
one of the kindest most down to earth
i remember meeting you and i never do
this
we're coming out of the bathroom and i
totally did what i say to never do and i
did that to you and you were so chill
and our picture turned out fantastic i
love it no i really like it i i
i posted it i was so excited to speak
with you today because
being you know with the un um and an
ambassador is a very unique thing
it's not something you know we get to
talk about a lot and yet you want to
reach people
to send this message of why
the un is so effective in if you do make
a donation
whether it's in money or time they
know how to get it to the right people
and in the right places
and they just won the nobel peace prize
yes it's very exciting to be working
with them you know i think a lot of
people
uh don't necessarily have the awareness
um
or the the context
of what it means to be a refugee i mean
if we just look at
2020 alone 80 million people were
displaced
you know that's that doubled from 2010
everything that's going on in the tigray
region in ethiopia there's a
constant need for resources for support
and sometimes it's just a hashtag
sometimes it's just
helping people be aware of what is
happening globally and how we can
support them
it's about being welcoming and and
making sure that we recognize that we're
all neighbors and we're all humans and
you know we're all mothers fathers and
brothers and sisters and everyone
deserves a shot and it's
and refugees aren't victims you know
these are men
and women just like us that have
incredible capabilities
and deserve opportunities to thrive so
you know i come from refugees my
grandparents were refugees
so for me i feel um
very responsible to this cause
personally because it could have been me
i might have not even been here if they
hadn't fought for their life and fought
to survive
really difficult circumstances so you
know i i
it's a it's a good fit i'm happy with it
i know the origin story of your
grandparents and how
that that is such incentivization for
you
but the way that you carry that out the
fact that you're walking the walk and
talking the talk and
traveling and spreading the message
and taking care of people bringing
awareness to this
it's so important and
i mean we all just want to bring
compassion and
love and you are so
so glamorous and you're still so
relatable and you you make it easy
to find the balance i would say that
you're one of the women that i'm like
well kat i mean you are giving it i
don't know if it's like 50s
60s a little bit of 80.
it kind of happened oh my gosh your glam
right now is everything i know that you
collect like vintage jewelry and have
such amazing style and it shows yeah i
just wanted
something fun you've got style for days
and
kat you know maybe uh because i was
doing
work with you n and then you know i i
stopped a little bit when i had my
babies and i'm getting back into it now
perhaps
maybe one day in the near future you and
i can take a trip together
i would love that i mean the real heroes
are you know the men and women that are
working at the refugees
and that are you know on the field day
in and day out with
you know trying to distribute resources
that they might not even have or be
running low on
and you know we're here and in hollywood
and we do what we can but our job is to
really
bring awareness and i love that you have
this whole segment on your show i think
that's
so cool thank you kat for bringing
the awareness of the un and
everything you're doing and so many
wonderful accolades that you're getting
rightfully so
thank you for coming on this show
[Music]